the jurogan experience
i'm loyal to the jokes my side is comedy
right your side is comedy when we're
doing stand-up yeah it's not like we're
gonna change the world yeah it's what's
the funniest thing to say sometimes it
is that teacher [ __ ]
the student is funny yeah that's the
funny thing yeah the 16 year old boy
gets a [ __ ] from his teacher that's
funny that's funny objectively funny
why'd you tell your mom high school
football coach [ __ ] a 15 year old
girl not funny make you angry that makes
you pissed off yeah so it's like 35 year
old man 15 year old girl you violent
[ __ ] that guy we got to get him out of
here right like we got to get a 35 year
old woman hot big cans how is that 15
year old boy
was it hard what are you saying i'm just
saying here's the thing
i actually think like this sounds crazy
but like i actually think there's like a
little bit of like heroism in those
women that do that because like they
know no 16 year old boy can satisfy them
sexually
like at 16 i was busting off
yeah but once but you could bust off
four or five times in a row once you get
that second one in you know
last time
i'm a champion
but here's here's where you'd get upset
if you found out you're 15 year old you
know so many women are like judging us
on our first nuts
listen
back in the day you had to come quick
because a leopard might eat you
[Laughter]
why why did i why did i learn this
excuse at 38.
babe there's leopards around built in
that's true it's built into the human
you get to come quick
and you never know the time to be
romancing bro it's not our fault did no
nature built us this way and they didn't
and it didn't build women needing to
come to get pregnant right if it built
women needing to come to get pregnant
they'd come quick too yeah do you know
they taught me that in high school
that women have orgasms when men
ejaculate inside of them
so now you're just in the 1990s 80s
that's great that's how dumb sex
education was tonight that's crazy they
taught us that
because i remember i'm i'm i know i'm
not remembering this wrong because i
remember being in high school and i
think i was like 14 or 15 years old
going i don't think that's right
my limited understanding of orgasms
never been around one i've never made a
girl calm i'd never had sex
but i kind of understood sex and i'd
seen porn and i'd seen like magazines
and stuff and i'm like
i don't think that's sad i don't think
that's right and i remember a buddy of
mine was telling me yeah girl can't even
come unless you come inside of her i was
like man this just seems sus
this seems very suspect
like this is like
that's how you have teenage pregnancy
well it's just right like if you learn
that in school right you're gonna nut in
these girls yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
like that's the worst thing you could
tell a teenager who's feeling insecure
and wants to satisfy a girl and now he's
gonna take the ultimate sacrifice yeah
and the first time like a girl came with
me it was like me going down to my
girlfriend when she was like 16 and i
was 16.
and i was like well obviously the [ __ ] i
didn't come inside right this is
[ __ ] yeah
but i'm like you sure you came like you
do you remember those days where you
weren't like did you remember the first
time a girl made me orgasm from a
[ __ ] i nutted so hard my ears rang
i've never had that since
i've been chasing that monkey ever since
i'll never forget this
dude when i was younger this i'm really
young i learned what jerking off was but
i didn't come yet i'm no [ __ ] i
would jerk my dick in the shower
stop
i would pee
and then i would put my finger in front
of the pee
and then i'd taste my finger to see i
was like well is this [ __ ]
i swear to god i swear to god in my life
i was tasting
pee
off my finger
because i didn't know what an orgasm was
i didn't know the feeling you don't know
the feeling yet so there's no way to
understand it and then i remember the
first time i actually did come and i was
like i don't even need to taste that
one of the first times that i had sex
with my girlfriend in high school i
pulled out and i shot a load of my face
in your own in my own face because i was
on top of her yeah and uh we were having
sex and i pulled out and when i pulled
out i just went
it just shot right in my mug because
back then you would shoot because i
didn't really jerk off back then yep you
had it packed in i was shocked
like a broken fire heart
puerto ricans playing stickball outside
yeah i was just going yeah yeah yeah i
hit my face once yeah i hit my face this
side a girl was on top hopped off boom
smack this side of my face right in the
face yeah right in the nose the mouth it
was just like and you know what you know
what ladies it's not that bad it's not
that bad
what's
that's true i don't want other guys but
theirs i mean we're so like intimate
with them like when we're going down on
them there's no like the fluids are
there have you seen that video there's a
girl she's on a podcast and she's
talking to this guy about uh she's a
porn star she's talking to this guy
about how uh her boyfriend was asleep
and so she wanted to [ __ ] her ex so she
ran down to the gas station cap have you
seen it cap i don't believe it's real
really it's in like toronto right like
the girls uh i saw i think six buzz
which is a toronto uh instagram account
like it's like tmz for toronto yeah i
don't know if it's in toronto or america
but she was saying she
her ex-boyfriend came inside of her and
then she came home and then her uh
current boyfriend ate her [ __ ] and was
talking about how good her [ __ ] tasted
he was eating her ex-boyfriend's come
cloud please cloud chase interesting do
you believe that honestly a girl would
do that i'd like to believe it because
it's disgusting or is it hot it's not
hot to me you [ __ ] weirdo
let me take you to a brothel in pompeii
bro we'll figure this out
some people want to eat cups they've
been doing this for thousands of years
well there's got to be a guy out there
that does want to
have a girl get cream pie and then eat
the [ __ ] out of her those guys are real
and he shouldn't even know he likes it
how's that meaning like
how much how much other [ __ ] do you got
to do before you're like i want to eat
another guy's [ __ ] out of a [ __ ] like
you know what i'm saying like how do you
go through the whole gambit of things
i've never had this conversation with a
girl she was like pineapple makes a
guy's [ __ ] taste better go how many dicks
do you have to suck before you figure
that out
i was thinking asparagus nope
roast beef don't like it
pineapple
hey what do you mention that i'm
hawaiian
whoa
blueberries
did imagine funny
imagine what a [ __ ] connoisseur you got
to be
the guy
you know what fruits or vegetables he's
been needing to notice
i taste coconut
yeah
oh [ __ ] crying bro